hey guys how's it going today we're
gonna be unboxing the new Nintendo
switch it comes out on March 3rd so huge
thank you to Nintendo for sending me an
early advanced console and I'm so
incredibly grateful so thank you guys so
much let's get into the unboxing now I
heard you started cutting into it oh
never ever cut towards yourself
especially with this ridiculously sharp
knife I'm so excited
there's Zelda amiibo I'm so freaking
excited I've been meaning for the
longest time to do an entire amiibo
collection because I have almost all of
them so one of these dates do it and
look for that but right now let's just
this is probably one of the most
incredible amiibo that I've ever seen it
it's the Guardian soda oh she looks so
pretty
mmm sweet beautiful switch look how cute
this little tiny cartridge is it's like
the size of my iPhone
oh my ear beautiful I am so excited that
this is the neon version we've got our
two Julie Kahn controllers here it seems
way more neon than the New York event
that I went to because the coloring in
that event was so bright you actually
didn't really get a good chance to
really check out the colors of these so
it feels good switch them around did you
get it did you get the joke look at this
this is this is the switch itself I'm
gonna get this so smudgy and like point
five seconds lift off the top more items
we've got our joint cut straps let's put
these in here put the next side in so
there's a little tiny groove right here
and you just slide this right in just
like this this looks so cool I
absolutely love these colors I think I'm
gonna go get a manicure this color see a
controller we got our switch screen
we've got an HDMI cable you know what
that looks like and if you don't here's
the charger here the switch essentially
not really sure the technical names that
they're calling everything I probably
should have looked that up but I would
call this the switch converter it
essentially converts what is happening
here on your little tablet this lens
right into your TV and from there it
switches tablet to TV it's the switcher
switch it up got your AC adapter here
USB HDMI out and right inside here you
can see that there is a little docking
port right there
whoo our other joke on strap this box is
really pretty too
I'm going to save it so to release these
you just have to push this little button
right here pull up and connecting the
joy cons to the tablet just as easy
[Music]
it feels pretty solid
it's my substantial feel now we have
switched in I like that this kind of
hides all of the chords so here it is
this is gonna look really good in my
office I could also coordinating to go
with the colors of the controllers so
here's where the game card is inserted
since we're I guess we might as well
take a peek at what the cartridge looks
like it's a little it's like the size of
an SD card this is supposed to make that
noise it's got a real SD card feel to it
in for a size comparison of the little
case not too much there Oh move it it
definitely is a little bit bigger full
sense right here I might as well unbox
these amiibo as well let's do zelda
first link Rider these look really good
the detail is incredible this is
probably the most realistic I think of
any of what's that little lettuce a snow
little snow bank
[Music]
oh great smell a very good smell to this
guy got the detail I just can't get over
it they did such a good job with these
I'm super impressed well I guess now
it's time for a nice little slow-mo
video montage of this sexy switch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you guys enjoy this video I'm
super excited about the switch and all
of the games coming out for it later
this year I'm gonna be posting a
Nintendo switch set up in my office so
I'll be giving you a set up tour of
where I'm gonna be setting it an ATAR of
sort of my gaming setup which is
directly behind where I'm filming right
now the seat is two cameras to monitor
so I can see what I'm doing
office all right let's it I'll see you
guys soon
bye I messed things up in boxes before
so there's a possibility of messing this
up I mean nothing is ever guaranteed
that's causing a little bit of a backup
[Music]
so I don't